hey everyone before we start today's
video we just want to say that when we
start any time science we have the goal
of making science as fun and interesting
as possible to a lot of different people
and now we're just thinking about how we
can do that in new and creative ways
will always be continuing with the
whiteboard series but today we want to
try a science sketch we did this before
we actually went to school about how to
write sketch comedy so the structures a
bit off but there's still a lot of good
science information there so hope you
enjoy it why are we doing this again
people asked like it speeds up your
metabolism but an Indian study of 88
health volunteers it decreased all of
their metabolisms India my physical is
where it originated so I think they
would know okay
mitchell's that decrease metabolism is
because of the yoga you see today is
about getting you more centered and a
controlled study it was found that women
who do yoga all the time like me had
decreased state and training body but
you're not a woman okay trust me I do
this often enough I think it's going to
also help with your tense mask but we
were the yoga injury study let's open
ourselves up people we're going great
yeah are you okay John okay yeah but you
you are okay
thank you for your energy today you're
welcome
this is the hardest part of any lesson
let's turn off the negativity of the day
and turn on the positivity you can do
this
turn off the negativity you know the
practice of yoga posture leads to
increased thalmic levels of the
neurotransmitter links to better mood
Yo Gabba Gabba and you know that yoga
can decrease anxiety more when compared
to other forms of physical activity this
is great you are great positivity
positive smiling children oh god what
did Mitch mean by the injury study like
that freaks me have a wait stop being
anxious why are you even bothering with
yoga breathing studies continue to show
that no matter how fast or slow you
breathe you generally get the same
amount of oxygen into your body slow
breathing will only increase co2 in your
blood
do you Oh God step out okay please close
your eyes thank you was that injuries
that are you were talking about
physicians have done studies I show that
yoga can cause injury have done
improperly but historically some yoga
gurus have tried to remove the word
injury because it's so healing but
science just shows that that's not true
surely injuries can't be that big finish
for me I don't Oh Mitch wonderful yoga
shoulders bring it back a little bit
good form
Greg Greg away from the wrist a little
more weight back in your legs you're
risking injury your pelvis up up not
it's okay we're almost for the puddle
Mitch you're impulsive lava thrusts
enough maybes genetic
well data does suggest that yoga results
in rapid gene expression alteration
which can explain the benefit i've also
rather but had there's actually more
gray matter and people who practice
[Music]
access games have shown significant
increase in bone density in those who do
yoga you do a lot of yoga Greg I'm sure
you'll be fine how many people are in
that study 227 participants I'll take it
okay thank you for watching we hope you
enjoyed it let us know if you have any
other sketch ideas that you'd want us to
tackle huge snake you to yoga yoga
studio for letting us user space into
standee her acting debut I think did a
pretty good job so subscribe thanks for
watching we'll see you next week see you